hey Andrew are you ready ready or not I
am no I wanted you to respond and then I
was going to say or not or not and then
and it didn't go that way I also was
also thinking about doing ready or not
here I come you can't hide maybe this is
about hiding maybe it's not we don't
know because we've never seen this movie
before and we're about to watch it for
the first time and you guys are watching
it with us so leave a like comment
subscribe all that good
stuff hit the
notification do you know anything about
this I've never even heard of this movie
is that true Craig asked me have you
ever seen rer and I'm like I haven't
even heard of this movie I don't even
know what we're in for but I'm excited
what you're not a samaro weaving stand
that's the only thing I know I just know
she's in Scream Six that's it oh and
that's where the directors come from
also the OC fans Adam Brody was on the
cover and I saw that picture I'm not
ashamed to admit I do like that show
except for season 4 was not great but
why would you be ashamed to admit that
it's one of the best shows of all time
California here we come ready or not if
you guys want to watch the full length
Reaction watch along where you syn up
with your own copy uh that's for the
super sexy rejects go to our patreon
that's where you could do that Greg and
John cover several shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs
included that's only for the sexiest of
people the people that are the most
ready or not I say it so sarcastically
no you got it in that was perfect well I
always get it in and we're gonna get
this in
right woof
now great first image okay going to say
that's a creepy way to
start Le's Gambit take a risk gain the
advantage was that good and Sinister I'm
not going to lie that got my heart heart
racing a little bit although State of
Affairs of everything my heart's already
just racing in general but yes you got
me there
already this would be a good house to
have a haunted house though maybe that's
what it is we actually don't
know come
on
hurry stayed on the same tracking shot
so far get in and don't come out Daniel
I'm scared
Daniel please they're trying to kill
me please oh my goodness he's in here
God
no oh my
gosh okay Daniel just threw him under
the bus out of him Daniel I'm so proud
of you
pleas well he had the guy who got shot
had a wedding ring on the woman was
crying for him so I'm assuming that's
his wife that was Elaine he shouted out
for her is this like a welcome to the
family type of thing don't think
so now we're about to see Daniel right
for better worse okay saman with them
big eyes poor sickness and in he help
till death to his part your family is
richer than God intimidates the hell out
of me your dad definitely hat you and
your alcohol brother keeps hitting on me
I want her to actually say that at the
wedding alcoholic brother keeps hitting
on me I feel like that's relevant I
honestly can't wait to be a part of your
moderately [__] up him moderately hi
hey don't see the bribe before it's bad
luck they are the family of the man that
I love and I want them to accept me
without you I'm one of us hey Daniel
I've been sent to fetch you hey the
drunk brother Han bro it's not too late
to flee you know you don't belong in
this family I mean mean that as a
compliment
foreshadowing we could just leave thanks
for the presence go yourselves no I'm
serious I'm serious I I'm giving you an
out oh no I would listen to this but
then we don't have a movie if anybody
ever gave me an out right before we got
married like that I think I'd take it
like why what what's happening but it's
an out together though it's not an out
like away from
me
are you ready for this oh
no good good uh drop wow that is a very
nice house I live there almost reminds
me of Billy Madison so much better oh
there's krid from Mission Impossible and
scream I think of him from Revenge smile
and smile please the more natural don't
take it personally they're just trying
to figure out if you're a gold digg you
know like my wife to the the left she's
pretty enough the last call the Dive Bar
kind of way oh Andy
McDow where the hell's your sister I'm
shorts fitcher's fault he's useless but
he's one of
us there good composer hi hi hey Andy
mcdell we've been waiting for you your
blood isn't blue
enough they said the same thing about me
stand tall and that was good advice
stand tall and F them
this duo with the screams and VHS Matt
and Tyler I have to
tell shut up take your pencil I tell you
something grace honey taking them off
wrecked into the point I like
it police sit here what Jesus anene can
you give us a
minute everyone is waiting yeah I'll be
down in a few minutes what the hell was
that that's that's why aene she has um
well she is boundary issues yeah you
think of course you have a secret door
servants Corridor they run all through
the house he has to tell her who's
waiting oh goodness I I trying to tell
you
um how is he going to say this so at
midnight you have to play a game it's
just something we do when someone new
joins the family shall we play a game
you draw a card could be back gaming
croquet Checkers for all I know I know
is his name Ben I know it's stupid it's
a little weird is he the little boy he's
the little one that was hidden in at the
beginning you just have to play and then
you you are officially part of the
family honestly it means more to them
than the wedding itself you are leaving
out a lot of details why not tell her
this before should have told her this on
the first date if we get married um you
might have to play a game of life in
death I'm sure Mr leale is with us today
so how much have you told her nothing if
she pulls that card are you prepared to
do what's
necessary loving this intro yeah sick
setup tension High way to drag it out
I'm sure there's animosity in some
family members who's spouse
like well yeah didn't survive versus
members who did survive it's like oh so
much animosity one of our children has
brought him a good one and you don't
know how grateful we are that you
brought Alex back to us try to bring him
back into the fold we're his family
she's obviously going to pull the card
damn hi Fitch Bradley I'm Emily oh your
dress is amazing I totally stoping you
on Instagram oh really
that's I'm so excited to be a part of
your
family he will decide that you continue
to
exist I would love to be part of the
woman's family she's so welcoming this
is how I picture Army Hammer's family
right so this room is reserved for
family members
only even if you survive is this some a
family you want to be part of or is it
you have no choice even if you survive
kind of thing I don't know but if you
pull the card they hunt you and try to
kill you I would assume that's but if
you make it out alive then what it's
like you have no choice type of thing
cuz now you're part of the club I'm
wondering or if they make you do
something that you can't
leave great-grandfather enjoyed his
games oh God her innocence is about to
be thrown out and she has no family
oh imagine if the person you're with
doesn't want to get married to you and
you're like why this is why he pushing
it off I if I was part of this family I
would never get married probably Victor
set up a modest Printing Shop during the
Civil War manufacturing playing cards
expanded into sporting goods and board
games plas family games acquired four
professional sports teams I may call it
luck but it's almost as if someone's
watching over us I love shots like this
among Mr leal's possessions was that box
Mr leale proposed a
wager if great grandfather could solve
the mystery of the Box Mr leale would
Finance any Endeavor of grandfather's
choosing we place a blank playing card
into the box drawing the card and Mr
leale will tell us which game to play I
got chess I got Old Maid I've never
heard of that really car game yeah my
dear it is your
turn oh my God what a wild thing this
is what a premise
[Laughter]
yeah what does it say girl it says
you're creepy and scary it says hide and
seek or you really going to play that oh
goodness you get to be the one to uh to
hide yeah just come meet me in my room
okay I not want for real so weird let's
turn the
Bell oh my gosh you're going to need to
be drunk for this you can hide anywhere
inside the house we then count 200 and
try to um find you no we never use the
cameras we always play the games as they
wouldn't played in great-grandfather's
time what's the time frame 100 seconds
no no I mean for the the whole game by
morning you stay hidden Till Dawn there
you go
Grace good luck you guys have a messed
up
family he said to meet her in his room
cuz he wants to protector I would assume
that's it is he able to who wants to
play a game
I would put some better attire on though
but she doesn't she doesn't understand
she's in a survival mode right now so
this is the greatest premise for a movie
I've seen in I'm not going to lie it's
very inventive I will definitely give it
that it's very suspense obsessed with
this right now it's very it's very
suspenseful Sam is so good and she's
selling every deey moment but also too
they're they're doing these other actors
are doing such a good job coming AC so
creepy you can tell how conflicted uh
those two are like they don't want to be
part of this obviously the husbands I
mean but even Adam
Brody she on the other hand she enjoys
this she just a psychopath Tick Tock are
or not Tick Tock are you ready or not I
should have played the song you said
earlier ready or not on the flip side is
she allow ow to self-defend herself I
think
[Music]
so that is such an easy place to find in
my opinion I don't know how she can lock
it how was your wedding night gra it was
just great just great I uh I sat an ad
dader I don't know is it an elevator
does it move you it can it can go up and
down it's just not not like you're
obviously your all right go save your
woman go get Grace she is Grace she's
dignity she
Grace Alex honey do you want some
company is this Adam Brody's wife I
think so I'm pretty sure it's ad Bron's
wife but like did yall think he was just
going to stay put and sit there they
did
[__]
Georgie oh I have a feeling though this
time when one of the kids sees her he's
not going to tell on her like in earlier
in the
film
Jesus jump scare good job let's
go what are we
doing get down grab your CH grab your
okay that got me so
much George whoa my God guys I found her
jeez oh my God and now she knows does
she look like she's wearing a giant
white wedding dress why did you shoot
her in the face sweetheart you're
supposed to name her she needs to be
alive for the ritual I think she
understands the game she's playing now
she dies does this count of course it
does not count it must be the bride hey
it's going to be
okay
move her we don't want Grace to see give
call it P yes it is you get the
links oh my
God okay sweetie you got to get we got
to get you out of here right now okay
stand up here we go yeah I would be in a
catatonic State too right now okay girl
no more you're a winner you got
that that was the dumbest movie of the
entire moment the movie people but she's
a winner she has to do it just not how
you
do that was funny though if they don't
kill you something very bad will happen
to the family you knew what would happen
if I pulled that car I I I didn't think
they'd actually go through with it no no
one ever pulls out it never
happens God stop talking so loud when
you marry into this family you have to
play a game and if you don't you die I
know that sounds crazy but you have to
believe me it happened to my great uncle
is wife too same thing happened to my
cousin Rachel same thing happened to a
bunch of people that I never even met
before I hope I marry into a family like
this it's a weird Supernatural mixture
that they just did interesting you you
brought me here you didn't warn me you
wanted to get
married yeah it's all your fault
straight down this H way until you get
to the service kitchen I'm going to go
down to the security room I'm going to
unlock all the doors I'm going to unlock
all the doors and then [__] run I
have to I would not be able to conjure
up a a thought
go go you do love him yeah I know I feel
you there but she he's his only chance
talk about toxic bro I get it though
I've fallen in love with some [__]
too girl we deserve
better I feel like he needed to give her
a weapon she needs a weapon get your
game face on baby I think though too
like he wants some kind of alternative
where nobody gets her but I feel just
for self self-defense purposes but
yeah yeah rip that [__] yeah I don't
cares about the wedding dress right now
what do you think happens if they don't
kill her do you think every other member
of the family
dies if if they don't kill her by Dawn I
just think just she's just part of the
family she won the game they said
something bad happens they believe if
they don't kill her something bad will
happen I guess we're going to find out
cuz I have a s slight suspicion she's
going to survive but we shall see she
could be anywhere I think she is going
to take out at least one or two of
them
yeah found
her Jesus people this is why you don't
do drugs and shoot I don't know what I'm
[Laughter]
doing there's so much tension
suspense I just can't even get a drink
yeah he doesn't want to play like this I
have to call the others no you
don't
no this doesn't end well for you I just
don't want to be the one to serve you up
I'm begging you Redemption Daniel you
already did this at the beginning this
is why he's a drunk it's true what they
say the rich really are different I'll
give you a 10-second Head Start take
it I mean that was somewhat generous oh
my God what's wrong with you Alex may
have been wrong to keep Grace in the
dark but do you remember how you reacted
when I told you about this you didn't l
o you couldn't wait to sign your soul
away where I came from and what my life
was like before I'd rather be dead from
your
lips they did a bait and switch here
they painted her like the [__] or the
him like the [__] now she knows
what's going on oh but Emily shot Claire
in the face so she's dead that's just a
side
note I love Adam Brody I forgot my gun
oh I hope she got it it's okay you don't
suck sweetheart here H why don't you
just use
mine oh I would not entrust her with any
weapons right now I just saw like that
knew it knew
it why does this always happen me
she's such a screw up so self-centered
why does this always happened to me come
on let's um go take a walk find your in
edible even you out a little bit even
you out a little bit we
must oh she groaning that air
oh oh my God this is a really dark
horror film sound design is incredible
oh my
God we should use the security cameras
maybe it was her husband that died oh
the one with the axe you have no respect
for tradition she's right don't you
think great-grandfather would have used
the security cameras if he had them it
is such a cheat to turn on the cameras
cuz I make the rules of this game yeah
rules are rules you guys can't
cheat is she going to become a badass by
the end of this I mean
she as I say I'm losing some family
members
tonight oh my God that gun is so old
school it's a cool look costume design
strong on this I would say take out yeah
it is I would say take out your cokehead
sister-in-law last she's not in a
position to fire at
you this is going to make a lot of noise
if she's able to fire
it oh God
she doesn't want to have to kill him
he's not part of the family right but he
knows the nonsense that goes on there
but yeah I agreed I know but she knows
you know they call him the help she's a
effing foster
kid that's why she has that
strength okay oh no his family member is
going to walk
in scared at hide and
seek I'm like freaked out kind of need
you to hold my
hand ah he's got a knife I think he
grabbed one too I don't know if he's
allowed to kill her yeah he's not part
of the game right yeah but he could surf
her up to them oh that's
true Let Her Go Let Her
Go this is like a master class in
suspense and tension yep let her go move
I'm afraid I can't do
that oh no don't show him how did you
really think I would be stupid
enough yeah [__] yeah I agree o I do
love that line that he was in support of
his wife that was great open the door he
is get
the that's my
wife he can't kill his dad yeah even if
he is a psychopath I guess still is your
father you got to help me she's
everything to me we'll get her out
okaye he knew it I knew
it there's still that little kid Georgie
running around right I believe so God
she's the help she's over
here she's over here oh my God she's
going to die right
now snitches get stitches [__]
seriously
o Oh I thought his eye didn't something
happen to his eye she yeah she put the
boiling water you okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I thought from the shot it
looked like he was completely Fun by
yeah you should never have let him leave
us excuse me I knew the girl would draw
that card and that he would face the
same choice I face you were right you
called that that's why she's so bitter
he's simply afraid of who he truly is
like I was you'll never know how it felt
that night to be told that the only man
that I'd ever loved had to die I should
have killed Charles myself why he is
meant to lead he's the good son do you
remember and why is he the only one of
us who has ever seen Mr laale in his
chair H interesting that's good
character depth with her character too
to make understand why she's so bitter
too I wonder if she's going to try to
convince him to kill her like family is
everything was he awake for
that I
think yeah this guy's useless is he
watching YouTube videos how to sober
your wife from Coke I love knives out
but truthfully this is kind of like a
better Knives Out is is that the Ryan
Johnson yeah it's great but all stuck in
the house
[__] oh did she just throw her the thing
not I think she dropped she jumped oh
she did actually jump oh
wow I thought she just threw the Gown I
didn't think she actually threw herself
out but she knows if she leaves him yeah
that's a good point maybe he might die
or they might kill him that's a good
point but she's going for it anyway
because F this I wouldn't blame her this
is information you should have told her
yeah but I don't think she can do it I
think she turns back yeah she definitely
will she's going to ammo up
she going to get on a horse somebody's
in here for sure who do you think it is
grounds
keeper uh it's the guy who's just
texting or it could be Georgie the
little kid I don't know hav't seen him
oh no if it's a little kid what is she
going to
do yeah good call finally I got one
prediction listen I know this is really
really
stupid oh my dear Lord he shoots her
through the hand bro oh my dear Lord
yeah yeah seriously punch that
kid um
you're you're going to need like some
serious medical attention right you got
to hole through your hand she fell in
the trash shoot it's probably Neosporin
won't even help the infection in that
then oh these are all the
bodies or what is
it what down there you had
bodies I can't even imagine the amount
of pain she's in oh god oh was that from
the beginning the guy was oh
[Music]
boy but Georgie's still up there too
yeah but does she have his gun I hope
she took his gun in this scenario if you
had to shoot the kid would you I mean
incriminate yourself we knew her white
dress had to get bloody at some point
yeah right and she's uh ready for that
Beetle Juice wedding with the red dress
this is a sick Halloween costume with
the converse and the wedding dress yeah
perfect attire
oh she's only got one hand
oh what a shot what a
shot did you know did you know did you
know that was going to happen no I did
not I did not know that I did not should
have thought
it oh it's right through the hands oh
god well at least there's already a hole
there
yeah
I'm not trying to be [__] but can you
quiet down I or they're going to find
you I feel you but I don't blame her for
shouting I can't imagine the amount of
pain that is this is like the greatest
movie ever it's pretty damn
good this is why people love
Samar she said oh Georgie thank God he
effing shot her take his gun though get
his gun who just throw Georgie down
there the cigarettes is like a whole
theme of this oh no she sees her and she
would rather die than go back to being
[Music]
[Applause]
poor oh oh no it's not even close to
Dawn too this [__] is dark don't you get
through oh no oh God who do you think it
[Music]
[Applause]
is thank who is it who is
it they said get the out of the way
she's out divy up the wedding gifts I
love how pessimistic he is this is a
game it is a game go wait for Stevens he
might need your help not you two I want
you out of the way try not to kill
anyone else she have an accent the whole
time Andy McDow I think she's she always
has an accent just in general just how
she talks it was just stronger than it
had been oh her poor
back and her hand me yeah I know but the
the hand happened to her her back she
did to herself to try to get out yeah if
you heard somebody screaming in the road
like that would you stop I'm sorry if
somebody was screaming in the road like
that would you have stopped I mean yeah
if they're screaming in the road like
that you think they might kill you I
mean yeah be definitely be apprehensive
but Daniel help I'd be on guard for sure
but I think Daniel's going to save the
day are you talking about Adam Brody
yeah he's saying Daniel help Daniel's
the one who initially got that person
kill he's going to get his Redemption
from the beginning I kind of think so we
all deserve to
die my kids don't mommy hey what are you
doing out here it's a nice black eye you
got immediately I shot her with that gun
I found why would you do that that's
what everyone else was trying to do I'm
so proud of you jeez IND doation much
she just said my kids don't deserve to
die it's a learned behavior I guess well
I mean yeah and we saw Adam Brody at the
beginning to he say he's right here yeah
he needs a Redemption Arc not that you
can redeem what you've
done he going to do hit her uh I think
that's exactly what he's going to do
yeah grab a rock or something yeah she's
she's got to be in such a low energy
right now why he like this maybe try to
have a conversation with
him
oh she's pushing on the skin thing yeah
where she burned him yeah it's so sad
that they have him doing their
[Applause]
bidding and she's tough to do that with
with her hand too every single foster
care kid that I know is a beast just
like so strong what's upbring I mean you
had a tough life already so yeah she's a
gangster I love this
character somebody in the back seat I
feel like the Elaine with the axe might
be in the back seat I don't know we
haven't seen her in a while I feel like
but she leaves him alive and she doesn't
run him over oh I think she heard you
that she was a beast no no no that she
was going to run him I thought she was
going to run him this is Justin your
call may be monitored for people trying
to kill me can you please help me that
the car was reported stolen I'm sorry
but I have to shut it down please Justin
you shouldn't have made the call thanks
for using trip safe have a great
night I hear how wholeheartedly oh no do
not put your head down do not put your
head down honey lift your head high look
around everything's going to
be that's why you should have ran him
over listen to Roxy next time
oh oh no cuz they need her alive
remember right right they did say that
yes Justin was the least helpful person
that's ever existed on the planet out of
people screw Justin we'll be there
shortly tell
him I know you don't want to but wow
this man loves his classical music kill
him kick him and kill him I'm surprised
she didn't run him over because she's
joh trying to kill somebody yeah no I
know but don't don't leave loose she
punched the boy in the
face oh she has a look of grit and
determination oh the music's so loud
he's not going to hear them she should
reach over and choke
them yeah turn on the music
idiot
[Music]
whoa that's an awesome shot awesome shot
I think the music in this is amazing way
to enhance every single scene
yeah I'm sure right now like as much as
it sucked being a foster kid she's very
grateful right now and also like Vu oh
no you don't want to kill me you don't
want me to die no I don't didn't she say
he was flirting with her at the yeah
drunkenly I am not who you think I am
Alex is the one who got out if anyone
was going to save you it would have been
him oh maybe he kills his brother I was
so far off in every prediction just now
and she made me feel like I could be
good too so if it comes down to you or
her I choose her except you still put
her in this position I don't think that
you believe that a girl that you've
known for a year and a half knows you
better than I do is there any world in
which actually we're assuming that Adam
Brody's character is the one that yelled
she's here but really it was Alex Oh you
mean like it's a Twist on that that's
what we saw and they wanted us to see I
mean but I'll make it right Mr
leel
[Music]
interesting take on Rich Society secret
society all that stuff you mean
interesting take on Army Hammer family
right there you go well we'll see if
they eat her probably watch this movie
and goes this is all very
true oh my goodness Alex you better walk
in right now oh he's coming prediction
does she live or die I think she lives I
think he's going to wipe most of them
out okay who do you think lives not the
dad I think her and Alex are going to
live why can't he do
it oh he's sick oh is it
poison oh what what maybe
poon Adam Brody poison them Adam did wow
yeah cuz he's not sick is that his
Redemption he said they all deserve to
die it's a good Redemption for him I
knew it well I didn't know exactly it
but I mean we were calling like earlier
on like there it's got to be a
Redemption for him I you'd help me I
didn't all I knew is at some point
somebody had to burn it all down thought
be me
Daniel oh your husband you really don't
care if I die you don't have to
do
o thank
you
that really sucks yeah but smart girl
she was she was like you're dead so I'm
gone she said thank you and I'm going to
do it right
here oh burning it all down this place
going down the thing is though if she
lives does Alex die I know she doesn't
think it's real
but no is she going to think is he going
to think that it was her who did it
I need you that his wife did
it you got to get up though dude it's
like some satisfying dialogue I'm not
going to let you hurt my family oh he's
going to have to literally pick between
the two of them like he claimed he would
yeah that was foreshadowing up yeah oh
she she going to hit her with the Box
she going to pull another card I don't
know no she just going to hit her with
the Box
yeah you don't deserve a f family you're
right no she doesn't deserve this
family oh
no oh no he walks in
Grace dude come on you know what they've
been trying to do to her all night
really still his mama's boy and he saw
what happened to his
brother oh
no no don't H she's in here what what
Mom said she knew I think he's the one
who did it as a kid oh you think that
was really more of a Twist I
do sh for us sham for us I still feel
like she's going to survive I just don't
know what's going to happen right now I
don't know I I I'm 5050
I'm
ooh you turn
oh she has a
knife what happens when the sun comes up
yeah like is it Supernatural like
they're saying or do they all start
dropping
[Music]
dead it is lost and they don't die yeah
forgive us nothing happens you played a
game for no reason now oh my God
uhuh should we play another game maybe
up for Checkers chess I knew it it's all
[__] oh
know Grace yeah F you I know it is too
late but I will not fail you again the
rules are the rules you can't do
anything
whoa who did it oh no she burst because
of the morning they are all going to die
oh he's killing them oh okay so it okay
so it is real I
guess I think you were right
yeah I want to go
home are the little boys
too yep I think that answers that I
played by the rules and I'm in control
later I really didn't think the
supernatural element was going to be
inserted sweetie Grace I'm really scared
don't touch me no okay I want
toor so she still gets the money right I
hope she gets everything but the house
is burnt down I don't think she really
cares right
now can you explain that to the cops um
they just naturally combusted into
nothingness whoa that was a
crazy all right you need to go to the
hospital right now for your hand oh
Legend but it's like an epically way to
do like she's a hero now with that the
rendition of how they're doing
it her dress is black look at all the
white still oh what a cool shot I love
her ma'am are you okay you hear
me I've got someone on the south lawn we
need paramedics over here I mean she's
going to need therapy the rest of her
life but she's fine she's probably so
proud of herself Jesus Christ what
happened to you
in-laws it was funny there was a lot of
a lot of jokes a lot of good humor damn
that was very good yeah no the setup and
the World building for this uh the whole
idea of this was just really well done
the uh the suspense too it just I loved
it um it's a good lesson here for all of
us if any of us ever meet a very rich
person who's got a very wealthy family
the first thing you got to ask them on
the date is do you guys have any type of
weird games you play after yeah rituals
that if we get married like cuz I saw
this film ready or not and I just want
to know is this something I'm going to
have to do so cuzz it is I'm so in I'm
with you also I just can't believe how
good that movie was yeah no I loved it
that was like just the greatest I mean
imagine coming up with that premise did
the directors also write this I'm
curious I'm not sure imagine coming up
with that premise and just being like
yeah okay let's run with it I mean
that's just so smart so different like
that classic it's almost like like an
Agatha Christy novel on crack
where it's just like we're we're stuck
in one location I love movies like that
but the way that we introduce it the
entire First Act or I guess until the
inciting incident of her uh pulling the
card was like what are they actually
going to do here and then even with uh
Daniel's character ending up being the
one that is the good guy whatever you
want to call him and Alex character
flipping and his mom being like I know
at the end of the day you're going to
choose your family and then him doing
that I just think it was such smart
storytelling really solid premise really
solid storytelling yeah and it made
sense too because from Daniel's
perspective like just he felt so guilty
with what happened with Elaine's husband
at the beginning and then just living
with that guilt for years and how I mean
what that does to a child and then
growing up with that and then from
Alex's perspective like you know again
like that's a very difficult decision
then Daniel was that was his brother
and/ best friend and then seeing his
mother like and again he didn't see what
happened to uh to Daniel so he figured
that it was his wife that had done that
and didn't realize that it was Daniel's
wife so and again to his wife's uh
defense she was she was in self-defense
the whole film even if she had K even if
she had killed Daniel like again she was
just defending her herself so that would
have been Justified but I think it was
more about the mom yeah the that speech
that she gave him like yeah no for sure
but yeah again either way just like you
side with her just because again she's
defending herself so it's Justified
either way but that was a good again
that was really good writing um but I
just thought this film just did such a
great job just balancing so many
different things from the humor to the
suspense and the tension and the jump
scares there's so many different
elements that I just really appreciate
it and just the the again the World
building and the setups and everything
just so many different things and the
psychological aspects of this film there
was just so many different and also too
I was just on my toes all F like I have
there was only like I feel like there's
only one thing I was able to predict
like with Georgie and the farm and all
that but I like I love when I'm I don't
see things coming in films I hate when
I'm able to see things coming so I think
that's you know credit to the writers
for you know me not being able to you
know see things that were foreshadowed
or coming oh I guess too like Daniel's
Redemption Arc too but I mean that's
that's pretty standard I mean you could
I mean I think we could both see that
was coming but it was just I was happy
that he got one because I felt no child
should have to go through that that was
that's terrible they really go down
every path I feel like they they fleshed
out every possible twist turn idea and
then they picked the best on for it but
you mentioned the psychological elements
and you know the psychologists talk
about between the ages of one and seven
really making shaping who you are as a
person and that you can't really um you
can of course change and grow and
overcome different things but who you
are a lot of it is really defined in
those years and we see that what she had
to deal with and we can only imagine
right she says she has no family she's
in the foster care system like how that
shaped her versus how Daniel and Alex
were shaped and even though Alex did
decide to get out at some point who he
is is kind of who he is um and it even
though he was able to make that decision
to leave it's Daniel who's the one who
was able to finally and when when she
says I knew you'd help me and he said I
didn't I really feel like it was 50/50
it wasn't like he was always going to
help her it really was like in that
moment after already seeing his sister
and her daugh and her son Georgie and
being like all of us deserve to die I
feel like he really had like a almost
come to Jesus moment where he's like
this girl didn't do anything she's too
good for our family he says that from
the jump right he did really like her he
hates his effing wife cuz she's a socio
and I think he just decided like uh this
is it for me like and and I think he
knew it would kill him one way or the
other I think he really believed that by
helping her he was going to die
regardless of whether it was by the hand
of his wife or by the sunshine in the
morning yeah I know I legit I I really
did feel bad for Daniel and I guess to
some effect I also felt bad for uh
Elaine I believe her name was as well
just from what happened to uh her
husband at the very beginning and also
too I I really didn't actually like with
the way it was end
um I didn't expect the actual
Supernatural element I didn't think they
were actually going to go there but they
had told us validity for it throughout
right they had shown us or said like
this is what happened to this cousin
this is what happened to this Aunt they
didn't play they didn't do this but we
didn't know if everybody would die
because we hadn't seen that yeah but I
mean I just thought that was just like
lines I didn't actually think that's
what I I just thought he was just saying
it just so people would fall in line and
just follow the rules of the game just
like Scare Tactics so you you know
follow so that they would do it but with
the game right you put the card in and
something comes out yeah so there's
hideand-seek and I believe no I'm just
saying that's a super natural element
and of itself right like that was the
one that I felt like was the first time
that they were queuing us into the fact
that this is not just um your
world yeah yeah yeah exactly because I
don't think that they were saying like
oh a different card pops out I think you
put the card in and he decides yes what
it is that comes out Lael right I
believe yeah yeah he decides yeah
exactly who they made the deal with but
yeah know and what did you think of the
uh how violent the film was I think they
did a really good job with that I feel
like it was the perfect level of
violence like it wasn't gratuitous
violence for the sake of being that I
think when you're dealing with something
like this the premise it has to be
pretty violent but it wasn't like super
violent um and then like here's all the
boobies you know just like for funsies I
think that the the premise is a bunch of
rich people are trying to kill this
foster child who their kid is with and
they know she has no family they know
she has nobody who's looking for her
they know that she whatever it is and
they they end up of course there's going
to be huge amount of violence for that
so I felt that it made a lot of sense
how about you yeah um sorry just it says
right there there's not sufficient dis
space to continue should I ask Craig
about that really Qui oh
um I don't know I just ask yeah Greg
when did it pop up I just noticed it
we're in the review portion but I just
noticed there's not sufficient dis space
to continue
recording I don't know when that popped
up I didn't notice
it okay so we're good to keep
going
no
worries yeah the joy your
Pepsi yeah this is for the sink thank
you thank
you yeah no I thought um well the first
scene where Elaine's husband was just
shot with the arrows there wasn't too
much violence there so it didn't really
how is that not too much violence well I
mean it is violent I just mean in terms
of graphic violence yeah Gore there you
go exactly so I don't usually I mean I'm
not the most it's it's it's hard for me
to watch violence but I mean it makes
for good reactions I'll give you that or
at least youall be the judge if you
think it makes for good reactions I
don't usually handle well like for
instance films like the saw films I
haven't really watched those I've maybe
seen like 20 seconds I usually don't
handle Gore well but I thought this film
like I don't know I actually enjoyed it
like I I thought it was fun to watch uh
just with the dark humor in this film I
just thought it like it it was a nice
staple with everything else I just
thought it all balanced well um I I
thought it was so funny though the I for
I think it was Emily or whatever the the
daughter like was the cokehead and she
couldn't like handle the gun or anything
she was accidentally shooting Maids like
why doesn't this ever work for me
whatever why is this always happen to me
yeah like and then they were reassuring
you it's okay honey don't worry about it
like there's always there are family
members like that so it's like that is a
very relatable trait and and in a Sea of
Monsters that we're watching it's like
there was something relatable there I
just found that like to be obviously not
when I say the word Charming I don't
mean like in the situ I just mean
Charming in the sense of like just it's
a family related matter that I think
that's something we can all relate to
but not the actual and also just the
self-centeredness of some family members
like why is it always happening to me
while you've just murdered multiple
different people I do think they did a
really good job with the Ensemble of
this everybody getting like I feel like
I had a grip on all of the characters um
using the word favorite but not meaning
like the best human but did you have a
favorite Ensemble member that's a great
I really love them all um the actress
who played aane she just did a good job
of just really feeling like she was I
mean she always felt like she wanted
that kill but she also felt like she had
so much like Ju Just from what happened
to her uh husband at the very beginning
you could tell like just how haunted she
was and you know she was just just uh
just feeling so pissed off about what
had happened and like again just the
word I would use haunted and just i' say
like her eyes were just telling a story
for me and I would say like she stood
out to me but I loved um what's waving
yeah she was phenomenal I just loved
watching her transformation um I think
you said it best though just because of
everything she had to deal with in the
foster care system it just it it was
totally understandable why her character
was able to transform into such a badass
because she's already had such a
difficult life um obviously I don't know
if anything can prepare you for this
type of situation but but they put that
in quick for us to understand just by
giving us a few lines it's like you know
um because I have a a lot of close
people in my life who went through the
Foster and you find out very quickly so
some are better than other some um
families housing that were better than
others so who knows maybe she didn't
have but based on her being like I have
no family it sounds like she's not like
in touch with any of the the families
that she was raised with so very quickly
you have a picture of her childhood that
like I think that they just did such a
great job putting into the script
because we can all imagine right why she
picked this guy why like what a fantasy
she thinks she's walking into this home
that's beautiful this like she's like
I'm so excited to join this
dysfunctional family cuz just cuz it's a
family so you can imagine what that
looks like for her and how much she
wants this yeah and then just to like be
gutted by that but yeah no Elaine like
again the animosity that that actress
just again all fantastic I love them all
that that they all just nailed that
creepy Vibe and um also too at the same
point that family Dynamic cuz even
though they were doing something
disturbing and disgusting I tood their
motivations and what they were doing
from the supernatural element of the
game that they were playing so like from
that perspective and also to from the
actors as well like at the end of the
day they're just actors and they don't
really know each other too well and
they've only got you know the um they're
they're just doing um you know they only
have so much time to rehearse and do all
that but I really felt that they had a
history with each other and that you
know that and such but um they did such
a great job uh in terms of that but did
you have a fa favorite family member I
think that probably it was Adam Brody
just because he had the biggest
character Arc um and I also just
everything that he said and did at first
when she's just sitting there looking in
the mirror talking to herself right
before the wedding and we don't know
what the premise of the movie is we
don't know what's happening we did see
of course the opening moments but we
don't know what's going to happen with
her um and she's just saying you know
and a brother-in-law who gets drunk and
hits on me I have such a clear image of
this guy just being the biggest douche
in the family right like and then as we
as we start to understand what's
actually happening here and he feels
guilty about the kind of brother he's
been his he thinks his wife is a
nightmare and he picked the wrong one
like uh you know all of the things he's
not a saint and and I don't feel bad for
him because he still made all these
choices however for him to have that
Redemption moment he stands in front of
her it was just so great um and then on
the other end of that my probably the
other person that I really was like wow
was Andy McDow because she had the
opposite with her character Arc right
like when we meet her for the first
conversation she's like stand tall and
say [__] him you know you got this babe
and she's like rooting for her and had
she pulled a different card the
Checker's card I'm sure that her and
Andy could have been great friends you
know and it was then to see her by the
end really try to be the last one to
nail her yeah yeah and then when she
looks and says [__] you you know she
stood tall and
I would state from character perspective
I totally agree with you that Adam Brody
was my favorite of the family in terms
of just act actor I would say Elaine I
just like I said she just sold me with
they all were they were all yeah yeah
again they were they were all fantastic
I love them all uh my final question for
you did you have a favorite Gore moment
because for me personally it was when
she stuck her shot hand into that nail
that was that's the one that really has
jump right yeah that was the most gory
despicably disgusting moment for me I
think that was a really good one I also
liked the moment not liked but the
moment in the fence I was about to say
going through the fence was especially
because what happens after that is that
like these are the moments that happen
in our actual lives not this movie
you're driving by somebody and you have
to make that Split Second decision like
what do you do and we have lost Humanity
in a lot of ways because because also
we're each individually scared now that
driver shouted [__] you get out of the
road so obviously that wasn't the case
there but like I think about this all
the time every time I drive by somebody
that is hitchhiking or somebody who
might need help and then you hear about
stories about people who go to help
somebody and they get killed right so
it's like you do you put your own life
first in those moments do you put uh
strangers life first you know so I think
that that Gore moment then leading up to
to no Prevail I was like wow that was
very very well done yeah for sure I mean
it adds to the groundedness of the film
I would say too like if you ever find
yourself in that situation you know you
have to assess um it's understandable to
drive away but also too don't shout yeah
yeah no no totally totally um I mean
there's also too you could maybe even
say like hey do you want me to call
someone for you and then you know again
it's it's all about assess a risk and
assessment she clearly is like a small
but yeah you never know how Mighty
somebody is you never exactly you never
know someone could be hiding and but you
just you never known today's day and age
I mean any uh nitpicks from you that's a
great question um you know right now
fresh uh nothing right now that stood
out to me that bothered me too much um
but I just like I said I just love the
balance between uh the the suspense the
tension the music by Brian Tyler I
thought he just did a great job I love
the dark humor uh the gore I just the
ensemble cast um as you mentioned Adam
Brody's character uh the way you got
that Redemption Arc and then the twist
with Alex's character and then how
badass she was I just there was so many
elements of this film I really
appreciated and again just the premise
of this just really brilliantly and I
just loved it so no nitpicks nothing
right now stands out I'm sure when I if
I think about a little bit more I mean
how about you I think that the there was
um the moment in the car right where
she's talking to that guy okay that's a
good one actually where I was just kind
of like I I understand the car service
turning off I but like he was she was
like somebody's trying to kill me can
you call the cops and he was like uh can
you not use profanity I was like that's
just like a normal person working a desk
job if anybody calls about that kind of
thing like and then you would call the
cops now the cops did come at the end so
maybe that was just the timeline wise
and and I'm not saying that the cops
have the quickest arrival time so maybe
he did call but I did feel like that
felt a little forced dialogue wise like
just slightly forced for the convenience
of what was happening I thought you were
going to say that was kind of dumb of
her to try and call someone someone just
like drive away get help instead of
actually trying to make that call I
thought you were going to go there and I
was going to say like when you're in the
frame of mind of survival mode you're
not really thinking in logical sense in
logical terms so obviously I've never
been there but I can only imagine how
much your heart is racing and you're
again I think it's totally reasonable
that she would be frantic and click to
call like you know you look for a phone
call my whatever it is but I just think
the guy on the other line was like yeah
you know for the all of the um that who
they refer to as the help were all on
their team but this guy isn't directly
working with them yeah and I do remember
there was one line of dialogue I I don't
think you cared for it was when she
started doing the Coke or something
there was a line that she said and you
were like you you thought it was funny
but you're like it was kind of stupid
too there was a couple lines where that
I was like that was funny but a little
Force but it did fit the tone of this
like this like obscure world so I was
totally okay with that but most of it
was actually felt very grounded dialogue
wise so then when some of those moments
stood out and then it's just a pet peeve
of mine too in movies where um this is
going to sound so ridiculous but like if
you're going to have a a drug be used in
a movie you need to know how that drug
is used and it was just funny to see her
like cup it's just like I don't know
watch some kind of like alapon dock
right something um anyway all right well
ready or not ready or not here we go
here we go that was that was good though
I really enjoyed it yeah that was I mean
I would say that that was as close to a
perfect movie as I've ever as I've ever
seen like it just really did it for me I
would give that a 9.5 out of 10 I'd
probably go the same ride and I also say
too I forgot to mention the tone of it I
just felt so Eerie the whole time and
from jump yeah for sure I'm with you uh
well thank you guys I don't think there
was a patron that he just told us to sh
out did I make that up I don't just talk
like this and they cannot even know that
are are moving do you know I could you
in triloquist in a different life I was
going to say are you triloquist I think
I'm pretty good at it actually if you
ask me um thank you guys ready or not
here we leave you can't hide you're
gonna find me and make you want me uh
that's pretty much it you guys rock and
thank you for being here with us don't
forget like comment subscribe all that
good stuff and we'll see you next time
see you
guys